สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะน้องเกรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้
วันอังคารค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 9
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนพฤษภาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันจันทร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 8 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนพฤษภาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
ค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันพุธวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่
10 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนพฤษภาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
ปีค.ศอะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ 2023 ค่ะ
ตอนนี้กี่โมงคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา 2 ทุ่ม
:00 นค่ะ
2 ทุ่ม 10 นาทีก็เป็นเวลากลางคืนนะคะ
เวลากลางคืนตอนนี้เนี่ยที่กรุงเทพฯ
ฝนตกค่ะ
ผู้หญิงอยู่กรุงเทพฯหรอคะ
ไม่อยู่ค่ะ
เรา
ยังไม่ตกนะคะแต่นี่เขาบอกว่าผมจะตก
นักเรียนคอมพิวเตอร์คุณเป็นเวลาประเทศไทย
คอมพิวเตอร์เนี่ยบอกว่าฝนตก
ไหม
ฝนตกไหมคะ
ฝนตกค่ะ
[เพลง]
ฝนตกฝนตกแต่ว่าก็เหมือนก็เป็นเหมือนวัน
นี้แหละค่ะก็คือฝนตกตอนกลางคืนนะตอนกลาง
คืนเนี่ยฝนตกแต่ฝนตกเบาๆ
ไม่ใช่เพราะว่ามันจะมีแบบฝนตกแบบ
ฝนตกหนักๆใช่ไหมคะ
ฝนตกเบาๆแล้วที่บ้านครูฟ้าตอนนี้ฝนตกเบาๆ
หรือว่าฝนตกหนักคะ
ฝนตกเบาๆค่ะ
เนาะส่วนใหญ่ต่างประเทศเนี่ยฝนจะตกเบาๆ
ประเทศไทยเนี่ยฝนตกเบาๆเนี่ยน้อยนะคะส่วน
ใหญ่มันจะตกหนักเลยอ่ะ
ฝนตกเบาๆน้อยนะคะประเทศไทยเพราะว่า
ร้อน
นะคะนักเรียนร้อนมากๆเมื่อวานเมื่อวานใช่
ไหมวันนี้วันอังคารเนาะเมื่อวานเนี่ยวัน
จันทร์เมื่อวันซืนวันอาทิตย์เนี่ยโอ้โห
ประเทศไทยร้อนมากๆก็เลยคิดว่าโอเควันนี้
วันอังคารเนี่ยฝนใช่ไหมฝนก็อาจจะตกหนัก
มากๆนะคะซึ่งฝนตกเนี่ยเวลาที่เราเห็นฝนตก
เนี่ยฝนมันตกมาจากข้างบนก็คือท้องฟ้าใช่
ไหม
ท้องฟ้าที่มีก้อนเมฆมีเครื่องบินมีนก
เนี่ยนะคะ
บนท้องฟ้าซึ่งเวลาที่เราเห็นตกลงมาฝน
เนี่ยมันตกลงมาเป็นอะไรคะครูฟ้า
ฝนตกลงมาเป็นน้ำตายตกลงมาเป็นน้ำถ้าครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยไปเดินตากฝนครูฟ้าก็จะเปียกจะ
หนาวมากขึ้นนะ
ใช่ค่ะไม่ไหวนะคะไม่อยากหนาว
เราก็เลยต้องมีโรคใช่ไหมมีร่ม
เนี่ยร่มเอาไว้กันฝนไม่ให้เราเปียกเพราะ
ว่าฝนเนี่ยมันตกลงมาเป็นน้ำแต่ว่าวันนี้
ครูหญิงจะมีคำถามมาถามครูฟ้าเนี่ย 2 ข้อ
เกี่ยวกับฝนนะคะข้อแรกก็คือ
ถ้าสมมุติว่าฝนเนี่ยไม่ตกลงมาเป็นน้ำไม่
เอา
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยคิดว่าอยากให้ฝนเนี่ยตกลงมา
เป็นอะไรถ้าไม่เอาเป็นน้ำนะ
ถ้าไม่อยากให้ฝนตกลงมาเป็นน้ำ
ตาย
นักเรียนคิดเหมือนครูฟ้าไหมคะ
คิดอะไรตกลงมาเป็นเงินหรอ
ทุกคนคิดว่าเป็นเงินใช่ไหมมันเบสิค
เป็นเงินดอลลาร์เงินเอ้อถ้าเป็นเงินอยาก
ให้เป็นเงินอะไรล่ะเงินบาทเงินปอนด์เงิน
ยูโรเขียนยังไงเนี่ยเงินยูโรเงินวอน
เกาหลีใต้
ว่าจะเอาเงินฟรัง
เดี๋ยว
เงินฟรังเนี่ยเป็นของสวิตเซอร์แลนด์นะแต่
คุณเนี่ยอยู่ออสเตรเลียใช้ดอลลาร์และเป็น
คนไทยใช้เงินบาทแต่คุณอยากให้ฝนตกลงมา
เป็นเงินฝรั่งหรอ
เขียนยังไงคะ
ไม่รู้
เขียนภาษาไทย
กูไม่อยากไปสวิตเซอร์แลนด์ด้วย
ฝนตกลงมาเป็น
เงินสวยนะ
แต่เงินเนี่ยมันจะมีเงินเหรียญใช่ไหมเงิน
เหรียญแบบ 1 บาท 2 บาทกับเงินแบงค์
ครูฟ้าอยากจะให้ตกมาเป็นเงินเหรียญหรือ
ว่าเงินแบงค์คะ
ฟ้าอยากจะให้ตกมาเป็นเงินแบงค์สิคะผู้
หญิง
ก็จะเอาแต่ว่าเปลี่ยนไป
ก็เงินแบงค์เนี่ยมันเบาใช่ไหมเวลามันตก
เดี๋ยวมันอาจจะปลิวไปได้ง่ายไงแต่เงิน
เหรียญเนี่ยมันหนักไงมันก็ตกลงมา
คิดว่าเจ็บอยู่นะ
ครูฟ้าสามารถเก็บแบงค์ได้ค่ะไม่เป็นไร
เพราะว่าจะหยิบแขนยาว
ก็คือครูฟ้าบอกว่าถ้าไม่ให้ฝนตกลงมาถ้าจะ
เปลี่ยนใช่ไหมจากฝนที่ตกลงมาเป็นน้ำครู
ฟ้าก็จะเปลี่ยนให้ตกลงมาเป็นเงินแทนแต่
ว่าผู้หญิงไม่เอาค่ะเงินเนี่ยมันธรรมดา
เหมือนครูฟ้าบอกว่าทุกคนทุกคนทุกคนเนี่ย
น่าจะคิดเหมือนกันว่าอยากให้เงินเนี่ยมัน
ตกลงมาเหมือนกับฝนใช่ไหมแต่วันเนี้ยถ้า
สิ่งที่ตกลงมาจากท้องฟ้าไม่ใช่ฝนไม่ใช่
น้ำเนาะไม่ใช่น้ำฝนนะ
น้องฝนอันนี้ธรรมดาใช่ไหมไม่ใช่น้ำฝนแล้ว
ก็ไม่ใช่เงินไม่ใช่เงินแต่เป็นอาหาร
ถ้าฝนตกฝนตกลงมาเป็นอาหารครูฟ้าอยากให้
มันเป็นอาหารอะไรที่จะตกลงมา
ครูฟ้าอยากให้มันเป็น
พิซซ่า
ต้องคิดดีๆนะคะ
คนไทยเนี่ยอาหารไทยเนี่ยมันเผ็ดถ้าตกลงมา
เป็นอาหารไทยที่เผ็ดๆนี่คือแบบ
ตายนะอยากให้ตกลงมาเป็นกุ้งเหรอคะ
ต้องมีกุ้งนะคะ
เพราะว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ชอบกินกุ้ง
ที่แกะหัวแล้วอ่ะกุ้งแบบนี้หรอกุ้งแบบที่
ครูฟ้าวาดเหรอไม่เอากุ้งที่ยังมีหัว
เอากุ้งที่มัน
กรุงเทพฯ
[เพลง]
มันจะเอากุ้งแบบนี้
และอาหารอะไรอ่ะอยากกินหลายๆอย่างเลยนะ
ถ้าเป็นอาหารที่เป็นเมนูอาหาร
ครูฟ้าอยากให้
อาหารอะไรตกลงมาเหมือนฝนมีก้อนเมฆอยู่
ข้างบน
แล้วก็ตกลงมาอันนี้ของฟ้าเขาจะเป็นกุ้ง
ใช่ไหมกุ้งกุ้งกุ้งกุ้งกุ้งกุ้งกุ้งกุ้ง
ตกลงมา
อะไรคะ
ลูกค้าอยากกิน
อะไร
นี่ครูฟ้าวาดอยู่ใส่จานลงมา
ใส่หัวเราเลยหรอ
เออมันจะฝนตกลงมาคุณฟ้าอยากกินผัดกะเพรา
กุ้ง
ก็อยู่ร้านอาหารไทยนะคะ
ใช่ค่ะ
ครูฟ้าอยากให้
ตอนนี้นะณตอนนี้ที่เราอัดวีดีโอเนี่ยครู
ฟ้าอยากกินผัดกระเพรากุ้งก็เลยอยากให้ฝน
ตกลงมาเป็นผัดกะเพรากุ้งบรรจุออกมาเป็น
จานไม่ได้นะครูฟ้ามันอาจจะแบบหกมันอาจจะ
ต้องตกลงมาเป็นกล่องไหมใส่กล่อง
มา
ไม่เป็นไรนี่ไงครูฟ้านี่ก็บ้านครูฟ้าใช่
ไหมครูฟ้าก็รู้อยู่แล้วว่าวันนี้เนี่ย
กะเพรากุ้งจะตกลงมาอาหารจะตกลงมาครูฟ้าก็
อาจจะมีแบบเป็นเหมือนอะไรใหญ่ๆอย่างนี้ไง
ไว้รองเหมือนเวลาเมื่อก่อนเวลาเราอยู่
บ้านใช่ไหมคะเวลาที่ฝนตก
ลงมาเป็นน้ำเนี่ยเราก็จะมีตรงนี้ใช่ไหม
แล้วก็มีตุ่ม
แล้วก็ให้น้ำเนี่ยมันไหลลงมารองน้ำฝนอัน
นี้ก็จะเป็น
อะไรอ่ะเขาเรียกอะไรอ่ะคอนเทนเนอร์เหรอ
รองอาหารที่ตกลงมาจากท้องฟ้า
อะไรนะเอาคอนเทนเนอร์มาลองเลยเหรอ
ก็กูฟ้าอยากกินใช่ไหมล่ะมันจะได้แบบไม่หก
ลงพื้นหรือว่าคุณฟ้าตอนนี้ครูฟ้าทำงาน
ร้านอาหารเสิร์ฟใช่ไหมคะครูบาจะเก่งก็ได้
ในการเหมือนเกม
รับอาหารที่ตกลงมา
ได้หรือว่าไข่เจียวก็ได้ค่ะ
ไข่เจียวกุ้ง
ผู้หญิงก็กำลังคิดอยู่แล้วว่าครูฟ้าไม่
เอาไข่เจียวหรอ
[เพลง]
ใช่ไข่เจียว
ไข่เจียวกุ้งด้วยนะคะ
[เพลง]
ก็คือแบบว่ากินเวลาเราหิวแล้วเราก็กินให้
อิ่มแต่ถ้าเป็นขนมล่ะอาหารที่เป็นขนมครู
ฟ้าอยากให้ขนมอะไรตกลงมาจากฟ้าเป็นฝนน่ะ
ฝนขนมอันนี้ฝนผักกะเพรากุ้งไปแล้วใช่ไหม
ขนมกูมาเลือกไม่ได้เลยเพราะอยากได้
มาการองด้วยอ่ะแล้วเรียน
ครูฟ้าเลือกระหว่างขนมไทยหรือว่าขนมฝรั่ง
ค่ะ
มาการอง
อันนี้โอเคอยู่นะรับง่ายนะมีกล่องมา 1 ใบ
แล้วก็รับมาการองที่ตกลงมาจากท้องฟ้า
ใช่ค่ะ
มากๆ
ครูฟ้าไม่อยากให้ฝนตกลงมาเป็น
ข้าวเหนียวมะม่วงเหรอคะ
อุ๊ย
ลีโอค่ะ
นักเรียนบอกว่ารู้จักแต่ครูฟ้าไม่ต้องรอ
ฝนตกก็ได้นะอันนี้เดินไป
ก็ซื้อได้
โอริโอ้ไงว่าชอบกินโอริโอ้นะคะ
ครูฟ้าชอบขนมที่เป็นแบบมีชั้นเนาะชั้น 1
ชั้น 2 ชั้น 3 เหมือนแฮมเบอร์เกอร์
แล้วก็เค้ก
เค้ก
อะไรคะอยากให้ฝนตกเนี่ยลงมาเป็นเค้กเนี่ย
เค้กอะไร
อยากให้ฝนตกลงมาเป็นเค้กสตอเบอรี่
เป็นโดนัท
พอฝนตกลงมาเป็นอาหารที่เป็นแบบอาหารคาว
อ่ะกินแบบเป็นเมนูแฮมเบอร์เกอร์พิซซ่า
เนี่ยคิดไม่ออก
วีซ่าก็ได้นะคะ
ไม่อยากให้ฝนลงมาเป็นส้มตำเหรอคะ
นักเรียน
ส้มตำ
คุณฟ้าไม่อยากให้ฝนตกส้มตำหรอ
คือส้มตำเนี่ยอร่อยมากนะ
มันอร่อยแต่มันเหม็น
ฝนตกลงมาเป็นส้มตำนี่คือมีร่ม
คิดว่าร่มเนี่ยไม่พอนะที่มีเสื้อต้องใส่
ชุดเหมือนๆอันนี้ป่ะเหมือนจะไปนาซ่าน่ะ
เป็นส้มตำไง
[เพลง]
ข้างบนเนี่ยมีนางฟ้าใช่ไหมคะ
นางฟ้าเนี่ยตำส้มตำแล้วก็แพ็คใส่ถุงแล้ว
ก็ตกลงมาเป็นส้มตำใส่ถั่วอันนี้โอเคอยู่
นะ
กาแฟหมดแล้วก็ไม่เหม็นนะแต่ถ้าแพ็คมาแล้ว
แล้วแบบว่าเดินมาแล้วตกใส่หัวปุ๊บก็เจ็บ
อยู่นะ
อาหารกับขนมใช่ไหมคะแล้วถ้าเป็นเครื่อง
ดื่มล่ะเพราะว่าฝนเนี่ยมันเป็นน้ำฝนใช่
ไหมมันเป็นน้ำฝนถ้าเปลี่ยนจากน้ำฝนที่
เป็นน้ำธรรมดาเป็นเครื่องดื่มเป็นน้ำที่
เป็นเครื่องดื่มอ่ะแต่ตกลงมาเหมือนฝนเลย
นะครูฟ้าอยากจะให้เป็นน้ำอะไร
กาแฟไหมอเมริกาโน่เอสเพรสโซ่คาปูชิโน่
ชานมไข่มุกไง
ของโปรดของครูฟ้านะคะครูฟ้าและชอบกินชานม
ไข่มุกมากๆ
หลอดใหญ่ๆอ่ะ
อยู่ที่ร้านเนี่ย
ผู้หญิงคิดว่านักเรียนถ้าเป็นนักเรียนใช่
ไหมนักเรียนอาจจะอยากให้ฝนตกลงมาเป็นชา
เย็นหรือไม่ก็กาแฟ
อันนี้นะคะสายใช่
ร้านครูฟ้ามีชานมไข่มุกไหมคะ
ไม่มีค่ะร้านอาหารไทยไม่มีชานมไข่มุกนะคะ
มีชาเย็นไทยมิลค์อะไรอย่างนี้มีนะคะ
แต่ว่าที่ออสเตรเลียมีชานมไข่มุกเยอะมาก
นะคะ
1 แก้วเท่าไหร่อ่ะครูฟ้า
5  6
ประมาณ 6 ดอลลาร์ออสเตรเลียเราว่า
ประมาณ
100 กว่าบาทไหม
330 อ่ะประมาณ
อีกนิดนึง
130 บาทนะประมาณไม่รู้เหมือนกันนะคะเออ
ก็จริงๆก็ไม่ได้แพงกว่าไทยเท่าไหร่หรอกนะ
ประเทศไทยก็มีชานมไข่มุกราคานี้แต่ถ้าคุณ
อยากให้ฝนตกลงมาเป็นชานมไข่มุกเนี่ยครู
ฟ้าจะให้ตกลงมาเป็นแก้วไม่ได้นะมันจะตกลง
มาเป็นน้ำนะน้ำชานมไข่มุก
โอเคค่ะนั่นโอเคนะคะเดี๋ยวฟ้าเอา
คอนเทนเนอร์ไปไว้หน้าบ้าน
อะไรคะ
เออแล้วก็มีถัง
แล้วก็ให้ชานมไข่มุกใช่ไหมเพราะว่าฝน
เนี่ยก็จะตกลงมาเป็นชานมไข่มุกสีน้ำตาล
ใช่ไหมคะ
ฝนเนี่ยก็ลงมาเป็นชานมไข่มุกแล้วก็มีเม็ด
เม็ดไข่มุกด้วยพี่แม็กไข่มุกก็โอเคนะ
เพราะว่าบางครั้งฝนมันตกลงมามันจะมีเป็น
เหมือนก้อนน้ำแข็งอย่างเงี้ย
เราเรียกว่าลูกเห็บนะคะนักเรียนเป็น
เหมือนก้อนน้ำแข็งอ่ะเออ
ที่เมื่อวานนี้นะคะที่ออสเตรเลียที่เรียน
คือ
ใช่มี Higher
เหมือนเอเลี่ยนเหมือนกันนะ
เหมือนเอเลี่ยนเลยนะคะมีชานมแล้วก็มีไข่
มุกตกลงมานะ
ปกติเวลาฝนตกบางครั้งเนี่ยมันจะมีอันนี้
ใช่ไหมลูกเห็บนะคะอันนี้ชามนมไข่มุกก็
โอเคเลยนะมีน้ำมีน้ำฝนที่ตกลงมาเป็นชานม
แล้วก็มีไข่มุกไข่มุกไข่มุกเอ้อก็เอาครู
ฟ้าเอาแก้วมาลองก็ได้ค่ะ
แล้วไม่ใส่น้ำตาลเองนะหวานหรือไม่หวาน
เนี่ยอันนี้ต้องคิดเอาเองนะคะ
แปลกมาก
นี่แหละค่ะถ้าสมมุติว่าฝนตกลงมาเป็นอาหาร
ไงมันจะมีอาหารที่เป็นอาหารคาวใช่มั้ยก็
คือของกินครูฟ้าก็จะบอกว่าเอาเป็นกะเพรา
กุ้ง
แล้วก็ขนมใช่ไหมขนมเนี่ยครูฟ้าเลือก
มาการองกับโอริโอ้นะคะส่วนถ้าตกลงมาเป็น
เครื่องดื่มครูฟ้าเลือกชานมไข่มุกแล้วนัก
เรียนล่ะคะถ้าฝนตกลงมาเป็นอาหารนักเรียน
อยากให้ตกลงมาเป็นอาหารอะไรก็คอมเมนต์คุย
กับเราได้นะคะส่วนวีดีโอนี้เราสองคนไป
ก่อนเนาะแล้วเดี๋ยวเจอกันใหม่วีดีโอหน้า
นะคะสวัสดีค่ะ
[เพลง]